[Music]
>> Our economic system in its current form
is simply not advanced enough to comprehend
the consequences of its own actions.
It is like a blind giant lumbering from continent
to continent, leaving incalculable ruin in
its wake.
I propose that we give this giant a set of
eyes so that it might tread more gently, and
maybe someday even look upon itself.
>> The CEO of today will be judged not only
by how well we change our industries, but
also by how well we lead our companies to
make positive impacts on the world.
>> When choosing a leader, we choose one with
[Inaudible] and worth.
Because a good leader should show good example
to the others.
>> The way in which we are growing things.
The way in which we are making products, providing
services, is having an unexpected and disastrous
impact on the planet that we live on.
>>We need to change and execute some new institutions
to set the right incentives, so that water
use becomes more efficient across the world.
>> Everybody who takes action actually has
an effect on at least somebody.
And obviously the more powerful you are, the
more influential you are, the bigger the impact
there can be across the world.
>> It's not just in working together, its
new ideas, its creating new concepts and its
happening as we speak.
It will challenge the way we think, it will
challenge the way we work, and it will challenge
the way we work with others.
>> There needs to be a more equal division
between the company owner and the employees.
>>Please take full responsibilities for your
actions and your inactions.
And leave a nice legacy for our children and
our grandchildren.
>>Extend hands and overcome obstacles to make
open trades and exchange of ideas and exchange
of cultures and exchange of people easier
in 2008.
It will certainly help make the planet a better
place [inaudible]
[Music]